[Music]
with our signatures today we will
formally declare the intention of our
three countries to replace NAFTA with
the u.s. MCA
a truly groundbreaking achievement
modern day agreement the new agreement
lifts the risk of serious economic
uncertainty that lingers throughout a
trade renegotiation process uncertainty
that would have only gotten worse and
more damaging had we not reached a new
NAFTA as idiomatically
this day is the culmination of a long
process based on dialogue and
negotiations that allow us to overcome
differences and to conciliate our
visions Mexican President President
Trump and the Prime Minister of Canada
they're signing this trade agreement the
president calling it the biggest most
important largest trade deal in US and
world history we're here at the Reagan
Library when Reagan traveled around the
world it was the g8 now it's the g20 and
the president there not everyone back in
Washington though is fully behind this
new trade deal what isn't in it yet is
enough enforcement reassurances
regarding workers provisions that relate
to workers and and to the environment
there also has not been a law passed in
Mexico in terms of wages and working
conditions in Mexico so when all of that
happens people will make a judgment
about whether they will be supporting it
we'll start there about the president's
trip to the g20 let's bring in our panel
from Washington national security
analyst Morgan Ortega's Leslie Marshall
Democratic strategists and David Brody
chief political analyst for the
Christian Broadcasting Network Morgan
your thoughts on this trade deal and the
g20 of role well I think the president
is right that it is very a historic
trade agreement it is trade is one of
the most arcane things that any
administration has to deal with and
getting this through especially through
the Mexican
Canadians who you know how about to the
very end on a few sticking points
related to dari is an accomplishment
however saying that it's a little too
early to measure the drapes because now
you'll have probably even tougher
negotiators than the Canadians and the
Mexicans and that's the Democrats in
Congress as we just saw
I'm really looking brett towards sherrod
Brown he's a Democrat who may very well
likely run for president he has the most
integrity and reputation as it relates
to workers rights into trade and I think
he's sort of my bellwether on whether
we're going to get true Democrat support
to pass this in the house in the Senate
it's not just Democrats a few
Republicans have piped up already a
Marco Rubio senator from Florida that we
did as currently drafted this deal will
put Florida seasonal vegetable growers
out of business it allows Mexico to dump
government subsidized produce on the US
market going forward America will depend
on Mexico for our winter vegetables
unacceptable there are a few others who
have weighed in as well Leslie yeah
senator Toomey's another he wants
everybody wants protections I mean the
union's want protections for workers
specifically if more jobs go to Mexico
which is a big concern not just by
Democrats and to the unions but over on
the right as well will there be more
outsourcing will they be protection for
investors will they be protection if
jobs go to Mexico or other places
overseas to a Nancy Pelosi's point
regarding the environment and protection
for workers the president has a
political win here breath but are we
going to see a win in Congress I'm
really not sure because there is a lot
of pushback on both sides just to Marco
Rubio's point agriculture is being
affected by this so a political win for
the president but I'm not sure what's
going to happen especially when you have
Democrats taking over the house coming
up in January yeah a different
environment come January meantime David
big issues obviously at the g20 the
president cancelling the meeting with
Vladimir Putin
but the biggest meeting yet to come
tomorrow night with the Chinese
President Xi well that's right and of
course all eyes will be on that meeting
for sure Brett I got to tell you there's
a lot obviously not just at stake but
here's what's going on
president Trump is not at a point now
where he can Bluff I mean in other words
it's time to pony up and what I mean by
that is he can't back away at this point
there's just no way and
so what does that mean well economically
America we know is doing pretty well
that's a good strong hand to go into all
of this with bottom line is if he can
come away with obviously something on
intellectual property theft and also of
all of this force technology transfer in
terms of what the Chinese are doing I
think that's obviously going to be a big
victory for this administration having
said that I think we've got a long road
ahead of us so what I will point one
point out is that over 200 was a 250
billion more in tariffs come January and
that's another issue that John Donald
Trump can raise I plan to ask defense
secretary mattis about a number of
hotspots around the world including
China Morgan here is the president
talking about this meeting yet to come
with President Xi we could make a deal
better be good thing I think they want
to and I think we'd like to and we'll
see but we'll be meeting with President
Xi and for the most part tomorrow I
would say would be a big meeting but in
the meantime people are working our
staff is working and a lot of very
talented people working yeah of laying
the groundwork you know art of the deal
here that's true I don't expect a
full-fledged deal tomorrow I think that
with a problem in the challenge here
which is different for the president
than say what he faced in North Korea is
we really have two competing factions
here clearly the economic and business
interests that side of his
administration would like to get to a
deal sooner rather than later because
they're worried about the effects of the
tariffs on the economy but if you look
at it from a national security
perspective Brett you know the Chinese
are not going to come out and admit
tomorrow what they've done on IP the
theft they're not going to reverse you
know three decades of how they've opened
operated in society nor G's plan for the
future his vision for how China is going
to lead the world so I really think and
and I can't wait to hear your interview
with mattis I think we're not to be
hyperbolic but we're at a moment when we
really are in a generational struggle
with China and I think that the
president one of the most brilliant
things that he's done in this
administration is for he and his team to
keep the heat on the Chinese
and I hope that they continue to do it
work towards a deal but there's no need
to come out of this weekend with with
some sort of magic deal and summing it
all up yeah Leslie and quickly you know
a lot of these world leaders know now
how President Trump operates the
Japanese Prime Minister came with news
of potentially two new factories
Japanese automakers to the US it seems
perhaps that the Chinese president will
come with some deliverables if it's not
even a big deal well you know Brett one
of the things that I think both China
and the United States are seeing are
that these terrorists haven't had the
impact that they want from our
perspective and I agree many Democrats
agree with the President on unfair trade
practices by China but our trade deficit
continues to grow and in addition we're
not seeing factories pick up and move on
to China to Vietnam and to other
locations in Asia and in addition to
that oh you know what do we want long
term one of the things the president
said in the 2016 campaign a promise that
he hasn't kept was that he was going to
come after China for their their
currency manipulation and I don't think
that's going to come up tomorrow I think
what's going to happen is both parties
are going to agree hey this tariff on
both side isn't working out the way we
wanted we can come to some type of a
deal but I think they're going to stop
going forward with more tariffs because
it's not working out for either side the
way they thought it would